جمله من التطورات التي تستحق المتابعه نقف
عند تصريحات جالنت التي يتوعد فيها يحيى
السنوار ويتوعد فيها قاده حماس بانهم
قريبا سيلتقون فوهات بنادق الجنود
الاسرائيليين الى اخر هذا الكلام يعني من
يخاطب بهذه العبارات الرنانه اذا كان يحيى
السنوار ومحمد الضيف بالفعل يقولون انهم
ينتظرون هذه اللحظات بفارغ الصبر ان
يستشهدوا كما استشهد قاده حماس
السابقون
كلام جالانت مثل كلام نتنياهو الذي يقول
انه على حماس ان تستسلم او ان تموت او ان
يموتوا يعني كله جعجعه اعلاميه تريد
ارضاء الجمهور
الاسرائيلي في وقت الحكومه الاسرائيليه
فيها تدخل في ازمه عميقه
واليوم في تصريح اخر مهم جدا نقلتها اريتس
يتحدث عن ان اسرائيل تقترب من انتهاء
العمليه البريه وتستعد لانهائها في في
غضون اسابيع الحقيقه ان اسرائيل تواجه
فشلا عميقا يعني بالاجمال الفشل يتمثل ف
اولا فشلها في اقتلاع المقاومه كما وضعت
لنفسها هدفا لم تحققه ثانيا فشلها الكامل
في فرض سيطرتها حتى في المناطق التي
دخلتها دباباتها وما زالوا يراوحون في
جباليا وبيت لاهيا وفي الشمال والنقطه
الثالثه انهم فشلوا في استعاده الاسرى كما
وعدوا
عبر العمليات العسكريه التي يقومون بها
وبالتالي هذا مع بالاضافه الى عاملين
اخرين يضغطان عليهما العامل الاقتصادي حيث
انه الان كل التقارير تشير الى ان اسرائيل
دخلت في ازمه اقتصاديه عميقه ولا تستطيع
ان تحتمل استمرار هذه الحرب لفتره طويله
وهناك ايضا الضغط العالمي الدولي الذي جعل
اسرائيل والولايات المتحده في في في عزله
تامه اضيف ال ذلك ضغط عائلات الاسرى التي
تطالب بالافراج عن اسرها و واليوم هناك
تصريحات بما في ذلك لرؤساء وزراء
اسرائيليين سابقين مثل براك
واخرين يقولون انه الاهداف التي وضعها
تنياه غير واقعيه لذلك انا برايي ه
الجعجعه لا تعبر عن عن شيء حقيقي بقدر ما
تعبر عن ضيق القياده الاسرائيليه التي
ستواجه لجان التحقيق قريبا و على الاغلب
ستضطر الى مغادره مواقعها سواء كان الامر
جلاند او نتنياهو نتيجه فشلهم في 7 اكتوبر
هم يحاولوا ان يغطوا على الفشل بهذا
الكلام في تقديرك ماذا يحقق القرار الصادر
عن مجلس الامن الدولي بعد تعديله امريكيا
بيخرج بهذه الصياغه الملتويه التي يعني
تحاول قدر المستطاع اتاحه الفرصه لاسرائيل
لاستكمال يعني ما تراه مناسبا من العمليات
العسكريه في قطاع
غزه هناك نقطتان مهمتان تتعلقان بهذا
القرار هذا القرار ضعيف وهزيل فعلا وغير
كافي لانه لم يتضمن وقف اطلاق النار يعني
انت تتحدث عن ازمه انسانيه هائله ومن
يسببها اسرائيل ومع ذلك القرار يقول اقناع
امتناع كل الاطراف عن تق منع تقديم
المساعدات من هي الاطراف ما فيش غير
اسرائيل هي التي تمنع المساعدات عن
الفلسطينيين وبالتالي القرار ضعيف وغير
كافي وان كان يتضمن نقاط مهمه اذكرها
لكن الاشاره الخطيره الثانيه ان الولايات
المتحده تعمدت اطعا هذا القرار ونا وت على
مدار اربع او خمس ايام لمنع صدوره واجبرت
الاطراف التي قدمته على تقديم تنازلات
اضعفه بالكامل اي وبعد ذلك لم تصوت له ما
معنى عدم تصويت الولايات المتحده على هذا
القرار حتى مع ضعفه لانه بالواقع هذا يرسل
رساله لاسرائيل انها تستطيع ان ت تمرد على
حتى على هذا القرار مع ذلك في نقاط مهمه
فيها اهمها رفضه للترحيل القصري لسكان
قطاع غزه وتاكيده ان غزه هي جزء لا يتجزا
من الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله عام 67
وغير مفصوله ولا يمكن ان تفصل عن الضفه
الغربيه التي يجب ان تكون مكونا في الدوله
الفلسطينيه ربما هذا جانب مهم جانب مهم
لكن الفلسطينيين مسلحون بعشرات القرارات
الدوليه التي لم تنفذ
طبعا ولذلك انا قلت انه الولايات المتحده
عدم تصويتها الى جانب القرار هو اشاره
خطيره اشاره خطيره لاسرائيل انها تستطيع
ايضا ان تتنكر لهذا القرار في نهايه
المطاف الذي سيجبر اسرائيل على التوقف عن
سلوكها وسيجبر على وقف عدوانها هو صمود
وثبات ومقاومه الشعب الفلسطيني وايضا هذه
الثوره العالميه التي جعلت سمعه الولايات
المتحده شريك اسرائيل في هذا العدو ان في
الحديد وجعلت سمعه طبعا اسرائيل في الحديد
وجعلتها معزوله تماما ه هي العوامل
الاساسيه التي ستغير الوضع ولكن نحن يهمنا
الان ان ان ان يستفاد من اي شيء ممكن
لايصال المساعدات بصوره كبيره لشعبنا الذي
يعاني الان فعلا من خطر المجاعه ويعاني
كما ذكر قبل قليل في برنامجكم من الامراض
ويعاني من نقص المياه وكل شيء هذا الاسناد
لشعبنا بكل الوسائل الان هو شيء مهم جدا
لدعم صموده وبقائه ودعني اقول انه اكبر
فشل لاسرائيل حتى الان في كل هذه العمليه
العسكريه هو فشلها في تنفيذ العمود الفقري
لاهدافها وهو التطهير العرقي لسك لسكان
قطاع غزه ودفعهم الى صحراء سيناء هذا
الامر فشل وسيبقى فاشلا بفضل صمود وبطوله
وبساله الشعب الفلسطيني شكرا جزيلا لك
الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي الامين العام
للمبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه كان معنا من
رام الله شكرا جزيلا
لك